so when when Julia asked me to do this
this talk at first she wanted me to do
to kind of talk about my work and talk
about how I came to icon carving and how
I you know how it works to be an icon
Carver but I really wanted to talk about
art in general and about you know the
place of liturgical art let's say in the
history of art and kind of how it fits
in what's going on in the world today
and so what I tried to do is I tried to
fit those two things together and so
hopefully it won't look like a strange
collage but it'll hopefully kind of
seamlessly flow together
the main reason let's say why I became a
icon carver I would say has to do with
my own faith it has to do with coming to
a point where I had this ability this
creative impulse and I was struggling
through university and then through the
beginning of trying to fit my work until
into a contemporary art I was struggling
to get those two things to fit together
and slowly discovering traditional art
and discovering the icon and and the the
Holy Church occult tradition is for me
was really a way to be able to be able
to join those things together and be
able to live my love of God in my faith
in an integrated way in what I was doing
so that's really like the main reason
why I do that
but for this actual talk that won't be
the frame of the talk I'm going to let's
say the the subtitle on my of my talk is
going to be something like sacred art in
secular terms and what I'm gonna try to
do is I'm going to try to talk about
sacred art within the context of the
history of the development of art and
why it actually makes sense that right
now we are seeing in several countries
around the world and in North America
this resurgence of traditional art and
of liturgical art so like like you were
told besides being an icon Carver I'm
also the editor of the Orthodox art so
for those who who want to know more
about this and more about what's kind of
happening in the world of liturgical
arts
from an Eastern point of view but we
also look at at at Western artists as
well but it's kind of seen through that
through that lens I would suggest that
you go online and just look it up we
have you know five years of articles and
artists pre artist previews and all
kinds of stuff so this there is right
now this this kind of strange resurgence
of liturgical art and a lot of people
are kind of coming up at the same time
and we we were doing this on our own and
discovering this language and
discovering this worldview together but
all separately and and slowly we started
to realize that there was this community
that existed virtually and was and we're
trying to kind of pull it together and
the work we're doing for Orthodox our
channel has to do with that has to do
with how can we create a sense that this
is actually something that's happening
so I'm going to show you first a few
examples of the artists that are that
are moving right now that are coming and
of course a lot of it is happening in
Orthodox countries and so there's a lot
happening in Russia and you can see some
of these these main artists some that
are really more traditional like Father
Zenon here on the right he's really
father Zenon is one of the pillars let's
say of this renewal of iconography
everything he does creates waves and
people kind of follow in his steps and
then people who are more looking to how
to integrate some ideas of modern and
contemporary art within their icons like
like Max and Chekov so we see this
happening in Romania and here as well
you can see those two poles someone like
young Papa who has who is integrating
some ideas that come out of modernism
tonal tonal colors in Ward geometric
presentation and someone like father Ely
a who is really exploring the kind of
luscious classical iconography that you
would have seen you know in the
Paleogene period and the high kind of
Byzantine times one of the great
countries that people don't hear about
that is experiencing a massive
resurgence of liturgical art is in
Georgia and there
their traditions run really really deep
and we don't even there are crazy things
happening like look at that dome that
was that's something that happened two
years ago and there's dozens of these
examples of churches being built with
massive projects of liturgical
restoration and and diving into their
traditional arts and and rediscovering
the the basic languages and the person
who's kind of leading the charge is this
artist here i'm iran gog Lidz
he started by restoring icons and then
finally fused like the best of Georgian
art with the best of Byzantine and the
best of of Russian and the best of kind
of Western medieval art kind of brought
it together to create a very coherent
and flowing language that a lot of
younger generation are following in his
footsteps and this idea of synthesis is
something that you're going to see all
through the talk like a lot of the
artists that are coming up they're
trying to create a synthesis of
languages of the past into something
that is coherent but it also taken to
account like that all the history at the
same time so it's interesting that
everybody is coming to those approaches
independently all over the world so here
are some examples of some Greek artists
like someone like George cordis right
here on the right I mean he is he is an
absolute artistic master he stands you
know in a church that's unpainted in
front of a white apse let's say and he
stands on a scaffolding with a long
stick and a piece of and a piece of
charcoal and he starts without his
sketch and he just draws out the Virgin
with her hands open in like half an hour
and it's there it's done and he didn't
prepare he didn't do anything if he said
he's really he's really a virtuoso and
here are a few examples of some Serbian
artists you can see in these ones you
can really see the the desire to in the
icon of st. Paul this is an icon of st.
Paul when he was struck by the light
while he was on his on his horse and so
you really get this sense of someone
falling over and he's really he's
integrating a lot of modern ideas you
can see my teeths in his in his
paintings you can see some of the early
geometric like the kind of naive
modernists coming out now into this
language which is still coherent with
the traditional language of the church
and so that's one of the themes that
you'll see one of the strong voices in
the West let's say like in Western
Europe and in North America has been
Aiden Hart Aiden Hart is a British
artist and he's really a master artist
and a master artisan he does everything
from painting icons to putting up
mosaics to making doors making altars
like he's really like a full-on
liturgical artist and he writes books
and he teaches at the princes school of
traditional art so he's like this really
central pillar of this kind of strange
movement that's that's moving up and
here in North America well you have
people like Andrew Gould
who is trying to create orthodox
architecture that has an American flavor
let's say so he he looks at traditional
American architecture and then tries to
see how the Byzantine layout of a church
how the how the traditional layout of a
church can be fused with some American
traditions so you can really see that
here in this in this in this church and
the cross here is something that that
Andrew and I did together so I did the
carvings and then he did all the other
design and all the framing and so in
North America we have quite a few of
these artists and so here are three few
artists that that you can look at it at
some other time and you can see the
different styles and the different
approaches father silouan who-who really
integrates a lot of contemporary art
ideas and then someone like Vladimir
Gregorio who is in the footsteps of
Father Zenon he's Russian like very
russian and then uh Nagri have just a
few examples of these artists but
there's quite a lot
a lot happening there's a lot happening
in music as well like there's composers
and musicians and choir directors that
are taking you know the the old the old
tones and the old melodies and are kind
of fusing them together creating even
new compositions but that are in line
with the traditional ones so there's
this vibrant movement happening I won't
talk a lot about music because I don't
know anything about music I'm gonna talk
about I'm gonna I'm gonna everything I'm
going to talk about it's going to be
about visual art but just that you know
that it's also happening in the in the
world of music so the question is what
what's happening like what does this
what is what does this mean like does it
even mean anything to see this vibrant
resurgence of liturgical art I mean I
personally I believe it does I believe
that this resurgence of liturgical art
is was inevitable in the grand scheme of
things like in the grand scheme of
culture let's say you see the thing is
that art is is in trouble of all the
stable notions that the contemporary
world is deconstructed and and deluded
to the point of returning them to dust
art is possibly one of the first to see
its fate sealed like if we were
struggling to know what a family is what
a man what a woman what spirituality is
if we're struggling to know what's up
and what's down the history of art in
the nineteenth and the twentieth century
has paved the way for the type of
decomposition that we're seeing now
abroad out in society so the history of
Modern Art was presented to us as
revolutions as a is brave questioning of
authority right each successive
revolution replacing the other from the
classicist to the romantics than the
romantics to the realists to the
impressionist the Cubist abstraction
then conceptual art and all of this was
seen as this constant kind of Marxist
emancipation of art where art would
emerge free and without any religious
social or aesthetic constraint but what
happened is that the end of
this process gave us not this kind of a
soaring cultural form that would act as
a support for some secular utopia let's
say rather than true Liberty it ended up
with this libertine self-indulgence and
self-importance I mean is there anybody
in this room who could name the ten top
contemporary artists today probably not
they're probably very few rooms that I
could be in where people would even know
who the top artists are in our world
today
so we're basically faced with the the
rotting corpse of a culture and it's not
just the decomposition because
simultaneously and possibly because of
this loss of actual value loss of actual
purpose in art we have this huge complex
of galleries and universities and museum
than the severe bureaucracy of
gatekeepers who control almost by Fiat
what it is that has value and here value
in the old sense of let's say spiritual
or moral or social authority has almost
completely been replaced by subjective
aesthetic experience social tastes and
yes value but value in a monetary
speculative sense where art is viewed as
a commodity to increase one's financial
standing one social prestige let's say
galleries will prop up artists and
collectors what they do is they outbid
each other on purpose so that they can
raise the value of their artists so when
you hear of a contemporary artist who
sold a piece for like twenty five
million dollars you have to understand
that the people who collect that man's
work agreed in advance to outbid each
other and then one of them buy the piece
so that everybody's work would now be
worth more
so that can explain to you sometimes why
you see these crazy things on the news
like some strange piece of art goes for
a hundred million dollars and you're
thinking how is that even possible it's
possible because when art is seen as
merely a vehicle of financial
speculation then you can make it work
that way if you want to and in more
socialist countries these elite cliques
of artists and socialites they give each
other grants and prizes to to perpetuate
their own let's say fragile existence so
when you consider this somewhat inside
joke of art because it is in a way this
inside joke that most of them don't want
you to know about the loss of true value
and art has led to this ironic Neel ism
or something which is seen not only in
the reduction of the work of art too -
just a mere object of financial
speculation but also you see it in the
work itself right you see this kind of
nihilistic chaos inside in the art that
they are promoting so they both of those
things go together and the nihilism is
balanced by this finely tuned but
implacable system of control these
galleries these financial markets and
Andy's museum so it's as if these two
extremely pathological things coexist
together I mean it's as if it's as if a
sculptor had created a statue which is
so fragile that he had that around it
had to be compelled this entire system
of protection and control just to
prevent it from melting away
and here this work of art is an example
of that this is a self-portrait by Marc
Quinn and and it what it is it's a
casting of his own face which is cast
out of his own coagulated blood and so
in order for this sculpture to exist it
has to be sold with like a freezer that
has to be plugged in all the time or
else that the sculpture is just going to
vanish and so one of his carving one of
his
sculptures actually did melt away
because the rumor is that it was in the
house of some big art collector and the
rumor is that someone who was coming to
fix up the kitchen and just kind of
unplugged things to to want to you know
to kind of fix the wall and then the
next day there was just like a pool of
blood on the ground so symbolism yeah
symbolism happens huh it just does no
way around it
so it doesn't take long to realize that
as a social as an actual social
manifestation as an embodiment of our
world that a cultural form so full of
self reference of irony no reduce to
these aha moments oh did you get the
joke you can just read it so it said
sell the house sell the car sell the
kids that's 25 million yeah so it
created a language that is so that is so
ironic but also the same things so
hermetic that it just it just can't be
sustained forever it's just impossible
it has to crumble this illusion of
progress in art that we saw at the
beginning this idea of this constant
emancipation of artistic movements has
basically now been turned into just
fashion and basically just this desire
to shock the art market to create
something that attracts attention like a
celebrity who wants a scandal so that
their work gathers attention when
someone like Marina Abramovic simulates
human sacrifice and cannibalism we can
say that we've reached the nadir of the
possible chaos engendered by the
contemporary art movement and then
there's this this came just like a few
weeks ago I'll let you read the headline
on your own
always like like just as in the time of
Noah I would say so the decomposition
fragmentation and chaos is is is really
an embody it is is an embodiment of our
culture and it shouldn't be surprising
that now it's playing itself out in this
polarization of society and in the fact
that we're looking around us and we see
this fragmentation happening it's as if
the art of the seventies of the 80s of
the 90s were this promise of what was
going to happen and now we're seeing it
happen not only in the galleries we're
seeing it happen in the street I mean
who would have thought that the
aesthetics of chaos framed in elite
systems of control you know wouldn't be
so amusing when they played themselves
out in the social realm so now what do
we do so do we just take out our fiddles
do we watch it burn and let out a mighty
bellow of laughter well that's tempting
I've had my own moments of temptation to
do that around 2001 I think it was after
entertaining my own possibility of a
career in contemporary art let's say
after I graduated from college I taken a
studio with some friends and those
friends actually ended up becoming
artists and and are still in the in the
art world in in Montreal but for myself
I came to the conclusion that I couldn't
do it that it just just to preserve my
own humanity and possibly to preserve my
faith especially I just couldn't and so
I actually took a hammer to most of my
work and I destroyed almost all of it
and I thought at the time that that was
it I was done I would never look back
and I remember I told my wife at that
time it's kind of a time of general
crisis in my life you can imagine we
started destroying things yeah she's not
a good sign but I told my wife I said
that's it I'm done I'm not ever gonna be
an artist again like I'm gonna just get
a job and like work and I just be a
regular guy and that's going to be it I
just remember she just laughed
and me and she's like yeah yeah yeah and
she said no no you really all come back
to it don't worry I know you will and
there's and then it's funny because
actually just about a year after I kind
of destroyed all my work I had already
discovered medieval art and iconography
and I had already started to foresee the
possibilities of that language and I had
started dabbling and carving at that
time was about 2003 so this is like this
is like my third carving and I remember
when I did that and I made that carving
the priest
I wasn't even Orthodox yet I was a just
a catechumen and the priest just said
keep going so but I didn't actually I'd
seen the possibilities but it just
wasn't yet I wasn't ready I think life
things weren't set up for me and nothing
was I had a lot of work to do I think
personally and in terms of becoming
someone else myself before that was
gonna happen and so after I did actually
I like a few months after I made this
carving I moved to Africa and we stayed
there for seven years my wife and I and
we worked with artisans while we were
there and I actually didn't carve at all
during the whole time it was in Africa
um but it was interesting because
working with artisans was really this
eye-opening thing for me it helped me to
see and to understand and experience a
different type of vision of fabricating
objects a different way to understand
how objects exist in the world how
they're anchored in everyday life how
they participate in everyday life until
making a chair or making a you know
making a cupboard or making a something
that is really just anchored in life you
know it was like the flip side of what I
had learned in the in the contemporary
art world
I never became like a carpenter I'm I'm
not I'm not that type of person but but
but to to to kind of live there we live
there for seven years and to live that
for that long really grounded my vision
and helped to form the way I am I
perceived let's say what art could be
already I haven't seen even the idea of
the icon as a possibility - it was just
all still vague for me so we returned to
Canada in 2010 with our two children and
what's weird is I didn't know I found
this out very recently do you know who
this is this is Camille Paglia and
Camille Paglia is uh she is a you know
radical feminist lesbian transgender
activist and in 2010 when I the very
year that I returned from from Africa
she wrote an essay called
religion and the arts in America and in
that essay she explained this quote I
would argue that the route to a
renaissance of the American Fine Arts
lies through religion and even like to
make sure that she did she wasn't
totally contaminated by saying that
herself like feel like because it's free
crazy that someone like that would say
that she adds she says quote let me make
my premise clear I am a professed
atheist and a pro-choice libertarian
Democrat unquote she tells us that quote
though I share the exasperation of my
generation with the moralism and prudery
of organized religion
I view each world religion including
Judeo Christianity and Islam as a
complex symbol system a metaphysical
lens through which we can see the
vastness and sublimity of the universe
knowledge of the Bible one of the West's
foundational texts is dangerously waning
among aspiring young artists and writers
when a society becomes all consumed in
the provincial minutia of partisan
politics as has happened in the US over
the past twenty years all perspective is
lost
unquote
so if you're surprised that and some
like an atheist non-conforming marginal
outlier would say something like this
you're not done being surprised we are
in a strange time we've come to the end
of the possibilities that the
revolutionary ideas could bring forth
we've come to the end of it we've come
to a world which is pretty much upside
down so we need to we need to understand
the situation we're in to understand why
someone like Puglia who who is or other
outliers of today other marginal people
of today are starting to say things like
that all of a sudden we have these these
punks and these provocateurs that are
saying conservative things sometimes
despite themselves I mean look at this
guy I don't know if you know this guy
okay his name is Matt Gavin McGinnis
okay and Gavin McGinnis is the founder
of vice vice just I just have to tell
you the name of their news outlet they'd
be called their news outlet vice there's
nothing less else that I have to say
about it okay
and so this guy and still like today
like he's gone through this crazy
movement and he still sees himself as a
punk and as and as a provocateur and as
a marginal figure and he still has this
kind of crass like vulgar way of
speaking and of talking about the world
but now he's there telling people to go
to church so there's something that's
definitely happening
so you see in a revolutionary process as
you turn the world upside down once the
world is actually upside down what's
left to do for those who are truly the
outliers those who truly question rules
who question the status quo what do you
do when questioning the status quo
the system right when that becomes the
status quo itself it's an impossible
reality so what does it mean to create
huge multi-million dollar state-funded
museums to house art which supposedly
questions tradition and authority how
exactly does that work so in her essay
puggly uh really intelligently points
out that one of the examples of the
bottoming out of art in the United
States were a few scandals where the
works of art that insulted Christianity
or works of art like that of Robert
Robert Mapplethorpe I'm not going to
show you these works of art there's no
point in showing to them but there's
there in the end in the 80s and in the
90s and in the early 2000s there was a
string of really horrific anti-christian
art that was being propped up and or
just kind of decadent work but she
points out that when the work like that
of robert mapplethorpe who had this cold
kind of sad oh masochistic photography
and and they tried to portray themselves
as edgy and as rebellious but when
they're completely institutionalized and
they're being funded by the state purse
like what does that mean how ironic can
you get I mean could you imagine my work
being funded by the state can you
imagine the riots if my work was was
funded by the state so whose edgy er
right who's more dangerous to the status
quo so Polly also points out quite
accurately that the progressive elites
they flaunt this anti-christian art
images of Christ and his mother covered
in you know urine and feces like
horrible stuff all in the name of
freedom of expression okay that's fine
but they don't have the courage to even
publish a cartoon of Mohammed it shows
that with Christianity on Christianity
on the decline in their culture they're
only capable of acting
of condescending strength and not out of
courage there's no courage left in these
statements maybe there were a hundred
years ago but not anymore
we just have to look at all these
university professors who are cowering
before the politically correct mobs
right present company excluded though so
what happens when the rebels have taken
the cushy seat in the Academy well the
first thing that happens is that there's
a need to perpetuate the increasingly
dissonant notion that their ideologies
are still subversive right that there's
still somehow the underdogs even though
their star artists are and advocates are
like are just these pampered socialites
who move around in circles of elite
power to quote Paul Joseph Watson you
can't be the counterculture and the
dominant culture at the same time so
let's take the case of this artist
Maurizio Cattelan
I've showed you hit the image of one of
his images the the upside down police
that you saw so when we read articles on
him right we read these critics and they
tell us that he has a subtle sense of
the paradoxes of transgression the
limits of Tolerance since the early 90s
his works has provoked and challenged
the limits of contemporary value system
through its use of irony and humor it's
like there's absolutely nothing subtle
about this
not only are there nothing subtle about
this there's nothing intelligent about
this either alright enough of
criticizing these people okay so I'm
going back to my own story so in Africa
the last year when I was in Africa I
discovered a way of making which was
more grounded in life a kind of humility
and integrated living in Congo I learned
about ancient African art I learned
about
the powerful patterns used in this type
of art this is kuba art um and they use
these geometric patterns and a couple of
them with stories and it acts as a kind
of you know algebra this algebraic
language of symbols that is integrated
into everyday life and so coming out of
the kind of art school brain space it
was exactly what I needed in our last
year in Kenya my wife my children and I
we lived in the Kesey region of Kenya in
a small town without a refrigerator
without running water on the top of a
hill overlooking green vegetation and
it's there that under the instruction of
a soapstone carver I learned to carve
this stone that I carved still today
that I fell in love with while I was
there in Kenya and the friends that I
discovered there they made me my first
knife you can see it down there in the
corner and it says it's this grinded
down file that they put together between
two pieces of wood and they had wrapped
it with a bicycle inner tube so the
bicycle inner tube is gone I've replaced
it with duct tape which is the our
version of a bicycle inner tube I guess
so this true grounded skill of carving
was really different from the do as you
please and you know defended with
unreadable Theory experience of my
university training so after seven years
our family returned from Canada and I
had a few boxes of soapstone that I
brought with me and my carving knife but
I had the idea that I would probably be
working in an office somewhere you know
find some regular job once again just go
back to regular life be a normal person
it's that's not I don't think that's
going to happen anymore
and so through a series of surprising
events I became an artist once again and
a great part carving that beautiful
stone that I discovered in Kenya and
without making a plan of it really I
became a professional icon Carver and I
by then I had come to the firm
conclusion that the most complete
solution out of the more
of contemporary art was to make
liturgical art to make liturgical art in
a certain way I come to the conclusion
that we had to go medieval we had to go
medieval on these artists so the idea is
Elaine Oh a lot of people you know they
would have come back from Africa with
this ayat with this art that's
influenced by African art let's say but
for some strange reason for me it was
not the case
seeing the traditional arts in Africa
being slowly being drowned out by
cellphones and Nike shoes and all that
in fact gave me a desire to revive and
to explore my own traditional art I mean
I know that African voices are going to
rise up and defend their language defend
their symbolic structures and I can't do
that and and in a way it would be silly
for me to want to do that and instead
learning about this made me want to
explore my own my own let's say history
and my own litre djegal art so if you
think of what I'm doing and you look at
the other artists that I presented with
you today before at the beginning one of
the things that joins us together is we
really have this desire to go back to go
back into the past and to take the
different languages that were developed
the traditional languages the this kind
of algebra that was there this this this
these relations of patterns that existed
and fuse them together as much as
possible and bring them together but
then why why why medieval the why go
medieval first off because one of the
reasons is because the modern world sees
the Middle Ages as like a kind of
catch-all for everything they hate you
know it's a kind of projection space for
all their their demons in our own home
school group I teach a history class
with my kids and some of their friends
and it was really revealing for me to
see you know a 12 year old boy who when
he he talks about the Middle Ages when
we started talking about the millet
Middle Ages he said that all
he thinks about is his mud right so it's
just muddy people you know just covered
in mud so I was pretty sure he got it
from Monty Python so I showed him I
showed him this how many times you hear
someone say that something is medieval
right that's something they don't agree
with is stuck in the Middle Ages so if
you want to make waves you know such a
demonized period of history it can be
pretty useful for someone who wants to
shake the system let's say but now I'm
exaggerating that's not really why I do
this
maybe a little and that's but the way we
go back into medieval art is not with a
kind of nostalgia it's not the way the
romantics looked at the Middle Ages
right it's not also the way the
Renaissance looked at antiquity it's not
this longing for a long-lost past you
know this this idealization of a simpler
time a work is not about the Middle Ages
like a love song is about a romantic
encounter the return to the language of
let's say the first thirteen hundred
years of of Christianity is our discover
to reduce rediscover this profound web a
profound pattern of associations a web
of visual and semantic relationships
which can bind us together right it's to
discover the full expansive version of
what POG Lia
quote a complex symbol system a
metaphysical lens through which we can
see the vastness and sublimity of the
universe unquote so we return to the
icon the return to liturgical art has
has actually more to do with let's say
how the for example the Jews the modern
Jews rediscovered reinvented ancient
Hebrew for the modern world too
rediscover this language which could
bind together a people that had been
broken and fragmented and spread all
over that's the end game of what we're
trying to do I think it's important that
that be clear a lot of people won't know
what puggly a means by a complex symbol
system a metaphysical lens and it is
pretty complex
I can't can't lay the whole thing out
for you right now
can't they out the whole vastness of
this symbolic system luckily we had
Jordan this morning kind of giving you
some hints of how profound these
patterns are and how deep they are in
our biological being and how they they
are deeply in the way we encounter the
world how they participate in our
consciousness but what I want to do is I
want to give you one little example I
want to take you on a little trip so
that you can see one pattern and it's
it's going to just be one thing but
hopefully it'll help you to kind of
plunge into what I'm trying to talk
about so this is an image of the
Dormition it's a it's a falling asleep
of the mother of God so the scene is a
funeral the mother of God is lying on
her deathbed and around her are the
apostles at her head is st. Peter who's
on the right hand of Christ who stands
right there in the middle at her feet is
st. Paul at the left hand of Christ
above her as I've said is Christ who
appears in glory in a mandorla right
that's the shape with all the Rays
coming out of it
he appears in all his divine glory
surrounded by angels and in his arms he
holds a little baby now the baby is the
soul of Mary which Christ is going to
carry with him into heaven now that
might seem pretty straightforward in
terms of an image once you know what
you're looking at it's pretty clear a
funeral with all the Apostles and
early bishops are there as well and
there's this image version of her soul
being brought in to God but there is a
bit of strangeness about that image of
Christ carrying a baby right why is it
represented that way why is Christ
carrying a baby so you see to understand
this image you have to consider other
images you can't understand this image
in isolation and you have to understand
that there are other images that are
implied that are connected to this one
that's what we mean we talk about a
symbol system which I've often called
this web or this mesh right that
underlies this interrelated imagery so
of course the image of Christ carrying
the soul of Mary is referring to an
image that we all know very well one of
the basic images of Christianity which
is of course the image of Mary carrying
the Christ child so there is a
difference between the two if you look
at both images there is a pretty
remarkable difference and it's that
notice that the soul of Mary is wrapped
up like a mummy so those are swaddling
clothes and swaddling clothes are not
often used in iconography but there is
one place where they typically appear
actually one almost exclusive place
where they appear and that is on Christ
in the icon of the Nativity and the
birth of Christ
so in this icon the mother of God lies
in a cave and is surrounded by an ass
and an ox Christ is placed in the manger
which is an animal food trough and he's
wrapped in swaddling clothes but once
again if you look carefully you'll
notice that the manger in this image is
a bit strange like why would a manger
have ornaments on it for example
and the reason why this the manger is
strange is because this manger actually
also refers to a tomb - a sarcophagus a
casket and the swaddling clothes are
also an image of Christ's shroud so here
is an image of the empty tomb of Christ
after the resurrection so in the icon of
the Nativity the birth of Christ is also
an entry into death by taking on mortal
flesh his birth is already in many ways
a dying okay so if in this Nativity icon
the birth of Christ is also a dying in
the Dormition icon the death of the
mother of God is also a birth so one
side the Nativity the icon of the mother
and the son is the flipside of the other
the Dormition as the divine logos joins
to his creation and to his church
so to creation so - the church is joined
to the logos so you might wonder why I'm
not strict already I'm not strictly
talking about Mary I talk about the
church I talk about creation well
there's something else that you need to
know to understand the image of the
Dormition and what you need to
understand is what you need to know you
need to know how this image was
represented in a church in the actual
church building so one of the main
traditions of the Orthodox Church is
that the image of the Dormition of the
death the image of the Dormition of the
of the death of Mary was placed on the
western wall of the church right so but
most of you would know this but a
traditional Church is oriented from east
to west the altar area that the
sanctuary in the eastern on the eastern
side
easternmost limit of the church is
slightly you know elevated and it's
accessible mostly to clergy and it's
considered the most holy place so to
make an analogy with time we could say
that the sanctuary or the eastern part
of the church which you see a top of the
image is the beginning of the church the
western wall of the church is where when
leaves the church in order to go outside
to go outside is to go out into the
chaos and the outer darkness
so the western wall of the church is the
end of the church okay like the rising
and the setting of the Sun in other in
other traditions instead of the
Dormition on the western wall we
actually place an image of the the Last
Judgement on the western wall and so you
can see this idea of the finality the
end of all things so do you know what is
the most Eastern image we have the one
that's up in the nail in the in the in
the apse most of you will know right
this is the image that we put up in the
apse
so in the apse in the most eastern side
of the of the church we have that image
so the two sides in this two sides
become like mirrors of each other right
and so the whole relationship between
those two sides between the Christ child
appearing and the mother of God and the
mother of God appearing at the arms of
the Christ child really becomes like
these two markers these two markers of a
space the beginning and the end of a
space it's both the you know the the
possibility of God entering into the
world and the possibility of man
entering into God and entering to God at
the same time you've seen this image
before you've seen this pattern this
relationship we saw it actually this
morning this pattern here is exactly the
same
as this pattern so I wanted to give you
a sense of how this is experienced let's
say the idea of entering into these
patterns because if when you stand in
the middle of the church it's not just
an idea it's not just a theory you're
standing in the nave and you look to the
east and you see Christ entering into
the church entering into ourselves and
then you turn to the west and you see
the end you see the the the falling
asleep the whole church gathered around
the mother of God and at the same time
the possibility of us entering into God
and so it's not just a concept we're
it's really entering into this
metaphysical structure that puggly had
talked about not just even mentally
physically being incited and
participating in it and so so when I
started and give you the last story
about when I started carving I came back
from Africa I didn't know what I was
gonna do and I met my bishop
I showed him some pictures of my
carvings and he said Oh would you be
willing to make something for me would
you be willing to make a Penta gear
which is a small miniature that he was
gonna wear around his neck and I was
like I don't know I you know I hadn't
done that before I never tried but he
kind of insisted so I said okay I'll try
so I went home and I contacted this
serbian carver that i had met online and
and i asked him would you be willing to
guide me through this
he said yeah of course you know help you
out and so i started to carve and then
he started criticizing i would send him
pictures of my carvings you know every
few hours i just sent him a picture of
my carving and then he'd come back and
say oh my goodness she looks like a cat
or she looks like she's on drugs or he
was just ruth it's my Serbians can be
seriously ruthless until he was just
just going into me and i was just
working working took several days to get
this thing done and you know so i I take
this thing and I wrap it in a piece of
paper and then I come to church on
Sunday
on a Sunday that I knew my bishop was
gonna be there and I you know I come up
to him I'm nervous and I give him this
little wrapping and I'm thinking about
the process and how I did it I hope I
did okay and I hope it's good enough and
I hope you know I hope that he's he's
gonna like it and that's what I'm
worried about him he opens up the the
package and he takes it out and he he
bowels and he crosses himself and I was
floored like I could have it was like
getting a baseball bat you know on the
side of my head I did not expect that at
all I should have expected it I mean
I've seen it all I've seen us venerate
icons all the time I should expect I
didn't expect it and in that moment I
realized I had that you know it's like
it wasn't my icon that did that it
wasn't wasn't my carving it was his
entering into that world through an
image of the mother of God entering into
that metaphysical space where he
embodies where he's he's inside that
structure out of which he can view the
vastness of the universe he stepped into
it and I did I had a little part to play
in that moment a little part to play and
I realized that you know Picasso despite
the fact that he can sell his works are
selling for 100 millions of dollars no
one went bowels before his paintings no
one kisses his paintings and so though
my part in that is very little I mean it
really is the mother of God to which he
is showing his reverence to be able to
play that little part in actually
participating in someone's life and
every day that he will wear that around
his neck and and the weight of that icon
will be the reminder of his
responsibility of the weight of the
service that he's giving to the church
you know to be able to participate in
that just seemed like the most amazing
thing and the thing about the art of the
icon is that the the visual language of
the Archon icon is that so
and as metaphysical as any visual
language that was invented in the
Renaissance or in modern art it has a
sublimity and a capacity to take you up
into the highest heavens but it is
totally anchored in life it is totally
anchored in function those objects have
functions that cross that I made is
taken out in a procession that that that
reliquary I made has relics of the
saints inside them and people use them
in their life so liturgical art goes
lower than all the contemporary art but
it also reaches higher reaches higher
because it can take you with with it the
contemporary art of today most of it the
language is so ironic and so detached
and so hermetic that even if maybe it
does touch something sublime it pushes
you away while it's saying what it's
saying whereas the icon and liturgical
art is meant to bring you inside that
space that paglia was talking about and
so hopefully that can that can help you
to understand a little bit of what is
driving this renewal and I'm not saying
that everybody should just make them
surgical art no I don't think so but
what I believe is that if we recover the
core if we recover the language if we
recover this possibility of entering
into that structure not just in our
minds but living inside it then all the
other arts will become more beautiful
will become more anchored will become
more like a hierarchy let's say they
will flow out and then touch people in
other ways they can be movies it can be
music can be all kinds of things but
that if we can recover at least that
language that unifies us then it's one
of the possible solutions to the morass
of contemporary art today so thank you
very much
[Music]
so hope you enjoyed my talk on the truth
and art this talk was given as part as a
conference I participated in in November
2017 with jordan peterson and several
other speakers at the northwestern cast
Northwest Catholic family education
conference it was a great event out
there I'm going to put up another talk
that was part of that event too talking
about sacred space and hopefully I'll be
able to put up the question period as
well where Jordan and I and the other
speakers answer the question from the
audience I want to tell you that every
year I give these icon carving workshops
their week-long workshops and we just
set the dates for the workshop this year
and so there's one in June June 3rd to
June 9th at st. Thomas Seminary in the
Bloomfield Connecticut and there's one
from September 2 to September 8th at the
DI owna retreat center in Salim South
Carolina and so those workshops there
for everybody I really start people off
at the basics we work together and it's
a great time because we spent all day
carving and learning to carve but then
the evenings are free and we just sit
around and we discuss and we get into
really interesting discussions and so
the food is great the atmosphere is very
beautiful and it's just a great it's a
great time to get to know people and so
I want to invite everyone who's kind of
following me on YouTube and if you'd
like to spend a week with me to talk
about symbolism to talk about orthodoxy
to talk about icons and at the same time
have fun carving a wooden icon then I'm
going to put the link in the description
it's given by the exam run school of
liturgical arts and it's also possible
to take the course for credit with
Pontifex University and so all that
information I'm gonna put in the links
and so look forward to seeing you soon
bye bye